allora ma cosa succede se volevo farvi
vedere sta cosa vi prego allora e allora
mi raggiunti ragazzi pervenute questo
video sono fa vj siamo ragazzi su just
ris 2017 che il mondo just dance che è
uscito da pochissimo just dance mi ha
contattato flop e mi ha detto ma di far
parte del nuovo videogioco di just dance
e io ho detto che cosa ho detto secondo
voi non siete pronti per questo ragazzi
non siete pronti per questo neanche io
lo sono però signore e signori
tu parti il jardin premi il tasto giu e
ci sono io o inserisci vip mail versione
dei b pro grazie grazie grazie
orlando bloom può accompagnare so che io
sono veramente just dance non lo farò
cioè sia c'è ma robusto di maroon five
ci sono io a caso allora ragazzine di
partire con questo primo video sul dente
1017 con la mia watt ma se permettete se
non prendo 5 stelle io che l'ho fatta io
sono un deficiente perdonarti dell'unica
cosa posso fare 5 se l'ho fatta io oi
signori shin beth nate direi che
possiamo particolare quella che mi
occupa da che figo che premiano la seguì
il ballerino come se fosse il tuo
riflesso nello specchio ma che il prezzo
con noi ero previsto va bene io sono
pronto è marco quale chiuse di prenderlo
ecco perché allora per mai partiamo
sono carico sono carico a molla state
per assistere una cosa epica ragazzi ai
pani jp mail fip spostate di tutti
quanto figlio e avrei dovuto merkel
grazioso io so cosa good ragazza lo sono
io non mi puoi dare meno di perfett
[Musica]
nell'attesa di nichi di la sua memoria
rho ballata un miliardo di volte fatti
semi guardati in faccia nel video si
vede che sono un po tipo cane bastonato
perché la dodicesima volta che la palla
penso ha detto non ha senso è bellissimo
ma gli altri che è stato parlo della mia
madre è geniale corsa come la follia ma
dove poiché chi si permette di
giudicarmi adesso sono io lì c'è
problemi cha i ragazzi sono di c1 style
se non avete idea come abbiamo fatto a
reggere per 4 minuti le fila del
possibile dai fermon altri fermi come ho
fatto a fare quattro minuti di pila lire
possibile dove l'avevo trovate le
energie cose sono diventato stefano de
martino tutto un tratto dove vai
non mi avrai la vj schifoso vip di
statista c'è quasi timidi di virtù ama è
max che dice sto cazzo a qualcuno mi
spiega al tempo che non ho capito anni
da homer signing drogano so che i
cupcakes perché che nel testo propongo
come una canzone di john lennon tratto
ragazzi
vado a scegliere me l'hanno fatta
scegliere quando mi hanno detto che la
canzone vuoi parlare io ho detto questa
perché è un gesto considerevolmente
bello sto facendo ma per perfette buster
formativa vj che stai montando questo
video metti il replay della mia faccia
quando faccio così ti prego voi non
avete idea di quante volte l'ho dovuta a
ballare per farsi capito venisse bene
ero stremato in faccia ma non potevo
farlo vedere quindi mi tenevo facevo di
poker bellissimo ragazzi sto video e
geniale basta è la cosa più bella della
vita ma uno stanco però per finiamola
sta cosa possibilmente con cinque stelle
grazie a un calzino diverso dall'altro
non so se essere notato basta
sono morto
[Musica]
quanto fatto fatto baby jane quanto
fatto che non ho visto neanche visto
quanto fatto una 22 cosa due non è così
come due stelle cosa
2 se cosa li pi l'ho fatta io la mappa
te ne sei accorto non o se vuoi tornano
indietro che lo faccio vedere o fatta
york 5 grazie la vedi con la porta lì e
da quella porta lì adesso centra un
fiume di ragazze perché io ho ballato
questa canzone hai capito quindi inutile
che fa il gradasso qua 5 stelle voi
doveste 25 uno dei video più epici da
quando cos'è sta roba è decisa decisa
cosa sto facendo non è satira così fanta
rom
in conclusione ci sono delle persone che
nella vita aspirano ad obiettivi
apparire in un videogioco
invero videogioco era il mio obiettivo
da sempre sempre fa vj di 12 anni che
stai giocando i videogiochi alla
playstation 2 e stai pensando io voglio
diventare parte dei videogiochi guarda
questa ragazzi non ci riusciamo a fare
tifo ci sarà tre canzoni tipo quella lì
tutto estranee
kakà
[Musica]
troppe emozioni in un colpo solo non
posso reggere più dato veramente
ma cosa può ben controllata l'ho trovata
fermi tutti se credete che lo stile di
ballo mino sia solo quello di prima vi
sbagliate di grosso
un carico sono carico dov'è la mia
patata qua non c'è sì ragazzi è già
tutto beppe meglio di quelle prima come
geniale due coach mimì ma immaginate
tassa sulla stessa bandana
sì però io sono forever alone cioè com'è
stato dove farete
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dico
solo non c'è più il fisico sul vecchio e
letali non c'è ragazzo sta lì dove vai
[Musica]
andiamo a comandare questa cosa anni e
anni di danza non mi hanno insegnato ad
avere una buona resistenza
sono stanco fresh aiuto e io con chi lo
faccio non tiene conto sentirmi non mi
fa sentire più friends lonato di quello
che non sono già a sì l'ho preso io gli
anni anni tesoro
oddio vuol dire basta ma ben poggiati
teneva basta così 3 stelle o fatto
meglio qui che in quella di prima ma
come ma ero io colori prima va bene un
bel po di che strano che non ci sia la
fila di ragazze fuori però adesso
arrivano secondo me ci sta mettendo un
po perché difficile da trovare a casa
mia però muori ragazzi piedi né che
questo per me è male il video vanno solo
morto abbiate pietà nelle prossime
settimane farò anche altri pezzi che non
ripete i just dance ovvero gli sia
piaciuta ragazzi ringrazio a ubisoft di
cuore per aver creduto nelle mie abilità
sicuramente non si è ricreduta per
niente ricordatevi se avete già test
andata a giocare la mia mappa e se fate
più di due stelle perché io non ho fatte
due ma in realtà è perché c'è una
fondata sono un 5
vabbè se fate più delle stelle mandatemi
la foto cambiano e caricate su instagram
collage tag just dance 2017 che così
vedo chi riesce a fare più di me
ragazzi cosa che mi è piaciuta al
momento è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come nei video trovate non è
venuto lo switch nella descrizione sono
divertiti screen ci picchiavano prossimo
vinto dai ragazzi
[Musica]